vous voyez c'est l'âme ça ça vous fait
quelque chose ou pas ça me gêne
bah ça vous gêne bien sûr c'est marrant
moi je vous ai vu vous marrez plus tôt
on se refusait à nathan ça vous fait
rire ça ne fait pas rien bah si je me
suis dit c'est vous qui me fait rire
c'est vrai les talents vous me chercher
je me vois arriver à faire vous menacez
en plus non je vais me chercher je vous
vois pas ce que je vous trouve pas
légitimes suis mais je m'en fiche
pourquoi je ne pourrais pas l'effectif
je m'en fiche sur quoi parce qu'il est
en train de faire l'apologie d'un crime
qu'il a commis
je fais aucunement toujours pas jugée
non mais ça je dis tout de suite je
viens sur le lendemain il regrette il
n'a rien fait mais il à titus son livre
j'ai séquestrés je trouve absurde donc
reçoit ce monsieur partout dans les
médias que tu le reçoivent tu as raison
parce que les autres ont fait donc à un
moment donné c'est bien aussi qu'on leur
commandant nous on a envie de savoir ce
qui les attend des excuses pour en
parler je trouve ça je trouve ça limite
que quelqu'un qui est en cours de
jugement viennent en plus fanfaronner
sur tous les plateaux de télé je vois
votre attitude vous regardez cavaillon
qui pleure ça vous fait marrer
je vous trouve vraiment ignoble voile
alors oui le monde attendait la manua
que vous avez qu'est ce que vous
répondez aux gens qui disent qu'il faut
pas vous invitez etc
c'est leur droit moi il avait tout de
suite regretté ce que vous avez fait moi
je leur ai vu c'est pour ça que je
voulais le dire vous êtes un culte
efforts sur quelques chiffres sur lequel
pardon excusez moi vol en bande
organisée séquestration et association
de malfaiteurs en récidive complicité
d'accord alors que vous allez finalement
furent avec le bulletin le butin à vélo
et ça vous êtes tous à vélo
oui c'est vous qui transportait des
bijoux une partie à part la bague qui
est dans un sac qui ne ferme pas c'est
sa seule inverse mais voilà prêt et donc
la caisse qui deviennent des bijoux ce
qui les bijoux ils ont toujours pas été
reconnue par nos moyens seront parcourus
mais ils ont été vendus tout de suite à
une chose qu'on met à l'abri c'est une
belle histoire a toujours
donc vous avez tir trouvait pas le butin
alors et le butin il a apparemment la
police d'être à n'était pas loin l'a
suivi mais l'a perdu en cours de route
elle a perdu bêta parce qu'en partant
vous croisez une voiture de police et à
sang voilà vous dit que c'est fini c'est
ça je pense que c'est cuit pour ma part
pour moi et ça qu'un un moment vous
tombez et vous fait tomber des bijoux
dans le caniveau ou c1 quand même nom
mais pareil alors vous pensez que
certains bijoux sont restés par terre
c'est incroyable non c'est quand on
connaît l'histoire que c'est ce qui
s'est passé c'est pas incroyable
simplement comme j'avais vu la voiture
de police avec le sacré remet pas et que
je tenais ans je tenais avec le guidon
d'accord ça m'a déconcentré
j'ai survécu jeudi à venir pc la rivale
arrive alive puis finalement elle n'est
pas venue et le temps que j'en prenne
les esprits le sac s'est pris dans la
roue avant j'ai fait rouler bouler mais
j'ai rebondi chez retomber sur mes deux
jambes et j'ai ramassé et il avait un
pneu crevé je crois je me rends en plus
des pratiques donc il est tombé et ça
s'est déversé sur la route